yoran on entend plus misano thématique
au mieux la veille c'est que
paul couet
bon cet étudiant la terre pendant quinze
jours c'est simplement des pour une
dissimulation ma maman deshors à petit
[Applaudissements]
le modem
la suspension immédiate de la formation
professionnelle
sa fille normale pour empêcher ces
détenus en circuler ça a été abordé à
venise au
label blue note
[Applaudissements]
qu'un jour la suspension du but tous
vont maintenant les eaux la relation
entre les ministres du culte et les
personnes détenues en individuel puisque
assez normal foyot un minuscule sio ça a
été abordé
comme il ya trois est venu en famille
parizeau décalé en cabine des pilotes
nous dit réduit sa nou lé au nombre de
la famille en cabine et biens détenus
sauf l'année six modèles bien sûr voilà
combattu la 9-5 faire aborder nous avons
fait possible sincèrement
non elles ont monté la roue à 5 ans dans
l'assise au lit
concernant le protocole claire des
départs ont chu des personnes détenues
et
proviennent
et non égalée au consensus a
immédiatement dit des grandes décisions
la compagnie a collé en la personne du
profit des crampons rangés dans l'auto
et nogaye vigilants puisque dès la fin
de semaine un mégaphone
on enlève ça